oh fantastic okay so um it's a pleasure
to
introduce the next speaker rahul jane
from usc
uh a berkeley grad of some some years
back
and uh well known in stochastic systems
and
optimization and more recently well
actually
quite a while now in reinforcement
learning we became buddies at uh
at the simon's uh program two years ago
um and uh i'll just let you go
sean thank you very much for the kind of
kind introduction and uh
uh thank you to you uh mehndi and emma
for organizing this uh
very interesting workshop so um
uh it's a hard act to follow after
excellent talks by munzer and alex but i
will try my best
and the flavor of this talk is slightly
different from the first two talks
so i'm going to talk about reinforcement
learning for continuous state and action
space systems
using generating models and it's only a
25 minute talk so i thought i'll
focus on something very specific a
specific problem
uh this is work out you know this builds
on work that i've been doing earlier
i've presented before at that's a joint
work with hiteshi but
like i'm saying it builds on prior work
uh
and i guess it's good to acknowledge the
work with the
former students and post docs and other
collaborators
with whom uh that happened okay so let
me start by just stating the obvious i
think we are all we've all heard
of the various successes of
reinforcement learning particularly
uh you know uh deep reinforcement
learning on
uh various kinds of uh games in
particular
um you know it's it's been very
impressive
uh but i think uh you know one thing to
note here is that
the this success uh however
impressive it has been has been on
particular type of problems
namely these are you know games mostly
deterministic move games
they have large uh very large uh state
and action spaces that's what makes them
really challenging
and but yeah like i said it's still been
very impressive but that does raise the
question whether
you know what about other kind of
problems whether
you know we're gonna have we're gonna
make be able to make progress
on other kind of problems particularly
problems coming
from robotics and you know autonomous
systems where physics matters
so here is a very prototype of very
simple mobile robot
you know we want to be able to just have
this robot walk and do various kinds of
maneuvers
and this robot has uh states and action
spaces
that are both continuous the states
spaces uh depends on the system
but it's of the order of 30 to 35
dimensions
the action space also depends on the
system but let's say that it's something
of the order of 10 dimensions
so these are not easy problems to handle
uh for
uh at least uh you know
classical uh methods including rl
methods
and but so and like like i was saying
physics
matters here and uh one would think that
one would need a model based approach
for problems like this
uh but given the complexity of uh such a
system i mean that has
proved quite difficult now one thing i
should say
is that this is not to imply that
problems of this kind are are still open
so there has been a lot of
there's been work going on for quite a
while on problems of this kind and
there's been progress
and but increasingly what's happening is
that you know we are
dealing with more and more sort of
complicated systems that are
harder to stabilize and and that and we
are basically pushing the envelope
so surprisingly uh you know the people
have
uh so like i'm saying so model based
approaches have not really succeeded so
people have been trying
model free approaches uh and at first
uh on first thought it seems that okay
you know physics matters here so how can
such
such approaches succeed when if you
ignore the physics
but surprisingly there's been some
success and
but the the the performance can at times
be fragile and there is also some
skepticism whether such approaches
uh are really doing anything more than
random search
and uh so that's sort of one point i
wanted to make
uh these are mostly based on such so
things that work on such problems
they're
based on deep reinforcement learning uh
you know there is long training times a
lot of hyperparameter tuning that needs
to happen
etc etc but the other point i want to
make
is that on problems of this kind we
train algorithms
in us in simulation using you know a
generative model or a simulation model
this is all done
offline and so there is some value in
problems of this
kind which is what this workshop is
about so i guess i don't need to
convince people about that here
uh but that's sort of the so
this is the setting uh you know more or
less the setting of uh
standard reinforcement learning so there
is a system with state
uh x action u uh f is the transition
function here
w is the noise and given the current
state x k
and action uk and noise w k you get the
next state xk plus 1
and then there is a reward r and then
the agent
takes the reward into account to
determine what the next action should be
so the setting here is that we are going
to assume
that the transition function f
is strictly speaking unknown but we
you know like i said i mean if this is
happening in a simulation
in a simulator then you know we we have
an implementation it just might be very
complex and we may not be able to write
it down
or use it in any kind of model based
approach so the point is
we you know we so so we have a black box
simulator and we can draw samples from
such a simulator at will
so that's sort of the setting that we're
going to consider
um the focus in this talk is going to be
on the infinite horizon discounted
criteria
and we know we're interested in finding
a policy that
maximizes the expectation of the total
discounted sum of rewards
and so we're looking for let's say to
start with the optimal
value function v star and of course uh
just uh you know one slide on stochastic
control 101.
uh you know we know that if the optimal
value function v star
it satisfies the development equation
where t is the bellman operator so it's
a fixed point of the
of the bellman operator and of course we
know that e is a contraction
and so by a binocular expand theorem uh
there exists such a fixed point
and then a very simple algorithm uh you
know
uh works to to find it that is you can
start
with any v naught and then just
iteratively apply the contractive
operator on it and then you guarantee
that that'll converge to the optimal
value function b star
and once you have that then from that
you can infer the optimal policy which
is
you know which is what we're looking for
i mean you want to deploy this thing
uh put this thing on the robot etc so i
just want to draw attention to a little
detail here
uh so i don't know if you guys can see
my cursor
uh so sean my cursor is visible
you're muted um yes yes okay okay great
okay i don't have a pointer so
all right um so uh so this
is you know the uh the uh
the you know in some sense this is also
defining the bellman operator and this
is second the second term in the
in the bellman operator is an
expectation of the value function
and this term is really the next stage
so this expectation is with respect to
next stage so that is written up here so
this is just a
restatement of that except that now
we are taking into account that the next
state is coming from some simulation
model or a generative model as now it's
being called
and so psi is such a simulation function
and
you know given this state x and action u
and some noise omega
psi x psi of x u omega
gives us the next state and since the
randomness is omega
then this expectation is with respect to
omega
so so the point of this uh point the
point i'm trying to make here is that
you know once you make this observation
you can immediately see that
you know you can uh use uh you know you
can generate
uh samples from uh simulator uh
and you can plug the plug those samples
in
uh instead in place of the expectation
and do a
sample average approximation and that is
a one very simple way of doing
value iteration all right
so uh like i said so the focus of this
talk
is on the setting where
both the state space and the action
space are continuous
if the state space is continuous and
just for this
you know for now let's assume that the
action space is finite
then we could do something like what i
just said which is uh you know just do
sample average approximation inside the
bellman operator and then you're
essentially doing an empirical variant
of value iteration
uh something that we have studied before
uh it seems to work quite well
numerically in many many contexts
uh there is of course a problem that you
know it still doesn't scale
with the state space size uh and of
course
for continuous state spaces you need to
do uh something else so you can do
combine that
this idea with function approximation
but the
the diff there's additional difficulty
arises when you try to
extend this to continuous action spaces
namely that in each iteration
you need to maximize over u and
you know you don't have any derivatives
or anything that are available here so
so it's not really possible to actually
uh do any kind of optimization
so one possibility is that you know
suppose you're
you have a compact action space uh you
know you can
just take some samples and take the
empirical max
and plug that in and uh you know and
then
uh you know you can still uh plug in a
sample average approximation for the
expectation in the bellman operator
uh so that uh works but it's not gonna
scale
and particularly when you go to higher
dimensional spaces it's not gonna scale
you can do sampling in smarter ways you
can
uh you can you can use monte carlo
research type methods to do sampling
that definitely helps but again as you
go to higher dimensional action spaces
that again runs into difficulties
so now value iteration is of course only
one type of dynamic programming
algorithm
you know policy iteration and active
critic types
frameworks are another and so in the
actor critic architecture which is
really generalized policy iteration
uh so what's happening is that
[Music]
and this is a very classical
architecture so what happens in such an
architecture is that
you uh you introduce a function
approximation architecture for
the q value function which is not not
too different from the
value function i was talking about so
far and you also introduce
a function approximation architecture
for the policy
for the policy and that's called the
actor and
in policy iteration type algorithm you
have a policy evaluation step
and then you have a policy improvement
step and now in the active critic
architecture you know essentially that's
what you do so you first you do the
policy you first you do policy
evaluation then you do policy
improvement
and you know and you keep on going until
you have convergence
if you have convergence so um maybe uh
you
might be useful to kind of just
elaborate on uh
you know things a bit uh particularly
since i will need
uh to to use some of this notation
so let's say that q is the the current
uh q value function that we have then
the operator g
pi is the policy evaluation operator
with the fixed policy pi
that you know that is defined like this
so it's essentially just the reward
function plus gamma times expectation of
the q
value function and the action is taken
according to the policy pi
so so again you know as i said before
there is an expectation here and
as you know alex also talked about this
is a very you know
we have been doing sample average
approximation forever so
we can do that here as well and
so the policy evaluation operator will
become an empirical policy evaluation
operator
and so it's very simple idea i think
this is
you know in some sense it can also be
regarded as being unavoidable
but from uh operator theoretic point of
view something interesting has happened
which is that a deterministic operator
has now become a random operator
and we don't really know and given that
this is embedded in some
algorithm where this is being iterated
over and over again we don't know what's
going to happen
all right so this is one sort of you
know the
so what we're going to do is we're going
to use the active critic architecture
and like i was saying the the both the
actor and the critic
the function approximation architecture
i mean you can pick your favorite but
they could be neural networks as well
and neural networks are universal
function approximator so
you know that's one attractive thing
about them uh
but uh you know it can be hard to make
i mean you know you can make things work
that's not really a problem that is
really the main thing that is attractive
about neural networks
uh but it can be hard to prove results
so what one could do and this is again
not a new idea i mean these kind of
ideas have been around for
you know at least couple of decades
so what one could do is that one could
uh so alpha here for example in the
policy network
the al alpha here are the weights in the
very last layer of the neural network
and theta are represent the all the
other weights
and what one could do is one could pick
all the other weights randomly and just
only optimize over the alpha weights and
so for example
uh you know so you have theta j so theta
j is just one sample
of the the weights in all layers except
the last one
and you get a number of such samples
each such sample
gives you a basis function psi of x
dependent on theta j
and then you just given its you know the
the the alphas uh in the last layer are
are to be to be determined i mean
they're deterministic so
pi of x has you know such a linear
function approximation form
right and you can do the same thing on
the at the critics side so that is the
neural network
beta are the weights on the very last
layer and then the where theta are
uh represent all the other weights and
then you just pick them randomly
and uh and then you have you know qx
comma u has uh this linear uh
you know function approximation form
except the thing to keep in mind
is that these basis functions are being
picked randomly
so it turns out that if you try to do
this then you
uh you know you can connect this to
uh you know doing randomized function
approximation in reproducible kernel
hilbert spaces
and reproducible kernel hilbert spaces i
mean they are very nice spaces to work
with they're also
uh you know universal function
approximators
uh priority neural networks i mean those
are the things that were in vogue and
but you know they do have difficulty
scaling up
computationally but you know our goal
here is
to both have something that is
sort of computationally simple at the
same time we would like to be able to
prove
that it's going to work okay
and just to i just want to emphasize
this is not a new idea basically what
we're doing over here is that
we are putting together a number of very
simple ideas
that have been around or are not
difficult to imagine
right and we're basically putting them
together
and uh trying to see if we can construct
an algorithm that of course not only
would i would like to be able to prove
something about it
but that actually works i mean that's
really the goal that it should work
and so now let's see if we can put all
the pcs together
so the first piece here is the first
step here is the policy evaluation step
and what you do is you uh get some
samples
from the product of the state and action
spaces so there are nq such samples
and then you do the empirical policy
evaluation
the way i just explained to you before
you know in the you use the
empirical policy evaluation so the
policy evaluation
operator and then just plug in sample
average approximation
uh you know from the from the
simulations
for the expectation and then you have
you know you're basically using a random
operator
so that that's what gives you q hat and
you get
that at these uh enqueue points
and then after that you just do you know
function fitting
l2 function fitting and that's it and
from this function fitting you know
you're going to get a function q
hat that is going to correspond to the
policy pi k
that was used to generate the actions
and of course
that's going to have uh to have this
kind of you know linear
uh function approximation form so beta j
times some basis functions
where where theta j are are random
and the thing to keep in mind is that
you know these these are these
uh the weights are chosen randomly in
every iteration so they are changing
they're not
they're not you know they're not fixed
it's not like you choose them once and
you fix them
and i think that also provides some sort
of uh
robustness though this probably needs to
be quantified
but you know if you somehow end up with
a bad sample of thetas
you know in the beginning you're not
stuck with them because you are doing
this in every iteration
all right so that was the policy
evaluation step so at the end of this
step so what you have is
that for a given policy you have some
evaluation of
its corresponding q value function as to
how good that is
and then then the the second step is the
policy improvement step
just like in standard policy policy
iteration
you get samples of the state n pi
samples uh according to some
distribution
uh from the state space and then
uh this is the q uh qk hat the function
that we just computed in the policy
evaluation step and you just plug that
in here
and uh this this thing in here
is the the policy that you're going
trying to optimize over because you want
to find an improved policy
so the point is that you you use the
current estimate of the q value function
and try to come up with an improvement
uh just like you do in
uh policy uh policy iteration and
uh it essentially amounts to just
finding these weights alpha so
you know you can use some gradient
descent algorithm your favorite gradient
descent algorithm to solve this so
numerically it's all very simple
and that's it i mean these are the the
two steps in the in this algorithm which
we call
rand paul so
as you can see i mean it involves some
sampling uh
you know l2 function fitting uh and
that's it and the key ingredients are
in active critic architecture and uh
function approximation but in a you know
with a shallow so again that the other
thing i would like to emphasize is that
we are not using a deep neural network
this is with the shallow neural network
all right
so like i said you know the part of the
reason for doing this is uh
you know can we prove something here and
it turns out that indeed we can and
there are
you know i know this is a little bit
dense there are a number of things here
but
um so nq and n pi are the samples
of the states and actions something that
i talked about in the two steps
m is the number of samples of the next
state that you need
in doing the sample average
approximation and j
q and j pi are the samples of the
weights of the neural network
for the the actor network and the critic
network
and turns out that if uh you know these
uh
these uh these numbers are large enough
and you do enough number of iterations
then the the l1 error in your q value
function is small with high probability
and you know so so one is able to get a
non-asymptotic result and of course it
implies
asymptotic convergence um so so that's
um
yeah so that's that's the that's the
main result theoretically speaking
um something that i would like to point
out here is that it is
universal in the sense that you know
it's a continuous
uh mdp so we are going to need some
regularity conditions to be able to make
progress
so we need some sort of lipschitz
continuity
uh on the transition function and the
reward function etc
but other than that we there is no
assumption on the structure of the mdp
that is being made
and like i said before it is you know
computationally
quite simple i mean there's you know a
lot of sampling going on
here for sure but uh you know
uh but and and uh one probably has to
run one has to run
uh you know grading decent algorithm uh
in
in uh each iteration of the uh of the
algorithm but that that's pretty much it
and uh i have not shown the constants
but all the constants are known and
the dependence on the key parameters is
shown here and the dependence on
epsilon ends up being 1 by epsilon
square which is quite typical
and then the dependence on delta is log
of 1 by delta which is also quite
typical i mean this typically comes from
the concentration inequalities that you
use
uh and the dependence on gamma
um you know that also is sort of uh
that's uh that can also be inferred here
um
i'm not sure if it is possible to
improve upon that uh but
yeah that's but we do have uh the
dependence
okay so this is the uh
so this is theorem and maybe a quick
word about
uh the proof sketch and then i will talk
about uh numerical performance
so actually it turns out that the proof
is not that difficult and
there is you know a number of steps so
first step is you just do sort of one
step uh analysis of
policy evaluation and policy improvement
which is actually turns out to be not
difficult at all
and once you do that then you should
look at each iteration of the entire
algorithm which is the policy evaluation
and the policy improvement step
as a random operator which you can argue
is probabilistically contracting in some
sense
and you know there is a very precise
sense in which that
that that which is implied
and then once you do that then you can
uh you can construct a stochastic
dominance argument
in the sense that you can construct a
markov chain that will dominate the
error process that you want about
and then the analysis just uh reduces to
analyzing this markov chain and you know
convergence and sample complexity
everything comes from that markov chain
and the markov chain is also very
easy to to construct so there's a very
natural construction of the markov chain
so this is sort of the
sense of the argument i mean uh for
those of you who have seen
you know uh some of my prior work i mean
you know it's um
some details are different but uh you
know it essentially leverages
you know uh these uh many of the
same sort of you know analytical
machinery that we developed earlier
which is a nice thing you know it
means that you know it's the proof is
not
difficult to operationalize all right
the big question is does it work
so this is on uh the the court appealed
robot that i showed you it's
in an environment called minitar uh in
pi bullet
and there are four things that are being
shown here so the last one is
this is some random search going on and
it doesn't work i mean i
you know that would be at least that's
what we would expect right that
the random search is not going to work
on such complicated problems
the other two are uh so the one in green
is something called ddpg deep
deterministic policy parent algorithm
which is in some sense state of the art
policy printed algorithm
and it works quite well and then
uh the the one in red is ppo proximal
policy optimization which is probably
the best
uh you know uh deep rl algorithm
uh for continuous control uh as at least
as far as we know
and the one in blue is our algorithm
rand paul and
and what you can see is that you know it
seems to have at least we can say that
its performance is sort of comparable to
ppo
and uh it does take more time so
competition so
it turns out that rand paul ends up
doing well
run time is more for rand paul than for
ppo i mean ppr is a really good
algorithm very well designed
but i think some of it has to do with
the implementation as well uh you know
ppu is
you know very naturally uses
parallelization and gpus so
runtime is pretty fast whereas with rand
paul you know
the code that we have our code is pretty
amateurish as you can imagine so i think
there can be some gains that can happen
by by having a sort of
you know better implementation okay so
this is
what it looks like but again the
question still remains does it actually
work
before i get to that i think i just one
more thing i want to say is a couple of
things i want to say is that
when in problems like this rewards
what's called reward shaping
is really uh you know sometimes it's the
bottleneck meaning that
you want the robot to have a certain
kind of
you know behavior or be able to do
certain maneuvers
what reward function should you pick so
that you can enable that and
a lot of effort is spent on that but
once you do that
then you know you across algorithms i
mean you can use that and
that's what we did over here the other
thing i want to mention here is that
you know rand paul as you guys as you
have seen i mean there is no there are
no hyper parameters or anything right it
is a very natural
sort of extension of multiple ideas
which are well understood
and you know there's no hyper parameter
tuning uh needed
okay does it work
okay so this required about uh you know
10 to 12 hours of training
more than what ppo required so ppo can
also do this i should not say that
people cannot do this
gdpg is less successful which is also
evident in the in the plot that i showed
you
uh but uh i mean at least you know so
uh just so i think this is
uh this is really the the proof of the
the pudding is in the eating as they say
so i think
uh you know theorem and the plots about
rewards and all that i think
those are irrelevant once you see this
okay
uh so with that i think i'm probably out
of time
uh so i'll just conclude that uh you
know what i presented is
is uh is uh
belongs to a class of algorithms we've
been calling empirical algorithms and
these are really you know algorithms
meant for
uh learning with batch data or with
generative models
uh these are uh simple
they're in in there they're universal in
the sense that you don't need any
sort of assumptions on the structure of
the model and
they have reasonably good numerical
performance uh
they do need a generative model so in in
that sense they they are a little bit
far from the goal of
reinforcement learning in that you know
that you don't
you know you you have learning
complete that's fully online uh
so one could argue that the performance
guarantees are a little bit weak because
you get convergence in
probability and then you know you know
with high probability bounds
um but you know once actually once you
ask for non-asymptotic performance
guarantees that's what you're going to
get anyways
but they do have good numerical
performance at least competitive
numerical performance
uh and uh yeah so the the
the ideas behind the algorithms are
simple and i think the
uh there is some hard work uh in in the
in the analysis but i think once that is
done
then the algorithm is pretty simple and
so so this is done in what the minotaur
environment on fire bullets so what
we're trying to do now is put this
on an actual quadripedal robot but first
you know we cannot do training on the on
the physical robot
so we we have we working with a
colleague
to to train you know a very realistic
model of the actual robot and if it
works in the simulator then we'll put it
on the
on the physical robot so that's what we
what's going on right now but
uh it's surprising once you
at least for people like me who do
theory that there is such a gap between
theory and
trying to make something work in
practice you know there are multiple
steps in the in this process
but it's a fun process all right thank
you very much
awesome uh thank you rahul so so here's
here's what i think we should do is um
since i cut off
questions for the previous speaker i'll
open up questions for either speaker but
let's give
rahul i'll give him
priority at the moment just because his
slides are up and all that
so any questions all about my chat box
um
there are two questions by gurglion
chava in the
q a checkbox i'm having trouble finding
it
oh there it is there it is okay so um
oh man so um oh so
g so gecko asks uh are you doing
anything fancy for exploration
are there any issues there yeah so
actually that's a very excellent point
so actually
we uh as we're trying trying to
translate this to uh uh
you know to to having it work on a real
robot so that's one of the challenges
uh because um i mean you have to be data
efficient
right and so there is an issue of
exploration
so in the minotaur that did not come up
we did not have to do anything fancy
but as we're working with the more
sophisticated model
uh uh you know of our actual quadriple
robot
so we are having to do some exploration
so there is
you know some entropy regularization
stuff that we are trying to do yes
okay cool and this this chapter has a
sequence of questions
and i'm going to start at the bottom
since i had the same question
about the benefit of the policy network
um uh okay
yeah sorry let me start with the first
well maybe i'll start with the first one
so is there an advantage to using
stochastic dominance
argument over oh yeah good
yeah so no it is just that it just
really simplifies
the argument uh i think otherwise it
becomes
um you know just too complicated uh but
this is not the only way to do it
i'm sure that there are other ways of
doing it
then the bound did not show dependence
on the dimension of the state and action
spaces
since it was emphasized that this works
no matter the mdp
uh dependence will be exponential in the
worst case sense
uh yeah you know uh
so there is definitely a continuity
assumption uh that we have to make that
as i mentioned so you need some
lipsticks continuity assumption on the
transition
function or the transition probabilities
and the reward function
i think
there is no explicit dependence on the
dimension
but it is happening implicitly through
the
you know some other way you know maybe
the ellipses uh
constants uh but yeah something we have
to look at
uh but we haven't gotten around to kind
of understanding that aspect
but as far as i can recall uh there is
no
you know dependence on the on the on the
on the dimension
but it is implicit the dependence is
implicit somewhere
then what is the benefit of the policy
network oh
why not just kernels for example yeah
so well i interpreted this question
slightly differently so the the
motivation for us
trying to do this was when you want to
go to uh
continuous action spaces you know and if
you
you know um you uh
so you know so so you can't like i
mentioned you
you know how how are you gonna do that
optimization right so one thing is you
can do
sampling uh you know you can you know do
adaptive sampling you can
try to use monte carlo research kind of
things right
but uh that also we tried that we
actually have a paper prior to this
in a paper prior to this that's what we
were doing but we could not make that
work on the robot
uh it was just uh for some reason you
know
computational scalability as well as
other things it did not work
and then we thought that maybe we just
need to do function approximation
for the policy also and uh and we
decided to use uh
neural networks uh so why neural
networks so that
so again
uh i'm not sure if i can give definitive
answer like
you know but i can explain the
motivation i guess but
you know why one not one why not the
other i'm not sure i can say
um so um
we you know prior to this we have uh
done function approximation
um like i mentioned in the arches space
and we were not able to make it scale
so again there was it was not working it
was you know partly a scaling issue
partly
just not working or not more complicated
problems
and the other was computational reason
that once you
put things into a neural network you
know you can use sort of
you know you know you can have you know
you don't need to program
so that you can use the gpu that was
really
you know a key motivation actually and
then we began to think about okay if
you're going to use neural networks you
still want to prove a theorem
how is that going to happen and of
course you know we were already doing
randomization of various kinds so we
thought okay
you know in our khs when we do function
approximation again we are using some
you know sampling idea and randomized
function approximation
we thought okay why not do that here as
well
so that i don't know if this answer this
answers the question i mean i i'm
explaining why i'm what
i'm i'm saying what our motivation is i
i don't know if
you know it is not to say that this
cannot be done in another way
and our focus was very much on you know
at least one thing
uh that was driving us was you know what
can we make
that will computationally work both in
terms of like
runtime as well as it'll work you know
like whatever whatever comes out that
whatever policy comes out
will actually work on on the on
on the minotaur robot
cool cool so um any other questions for
a whole out there
um um so i have questions yeah
again both monger and alex but
maybe i'll start with alex in the
reverse order
um so alex you uh thank you for
discussing the notion of risk measures
in
uh multi-stage stochastic programming so
um i think
um so since we didn't have enough time
so i
i think i i still hope to get a better
understanding about
what's the correct notion of risk matter
in
multi-stage stochastic organization so i
i think i've
seen papers was very different
set of definitions of risk measures some
involving time consistency
some do not so um so i guess my question
is in your mind what would be the right
way or
the most reasonable way to think about
risk measures and also when we define
risk measures
it seems like some mismatches are
defined to make analysis
straightforward but is that the way to
go
or well maybe this is fundamentally a
heart or that's a hard question
so i just want to hear your view on this
i hope he's here oh we lost him
that's too bad oh yeah oh that's too bad
yeah
okay anybody else would answer that one
no i don't know i think
i think i think he's he's here and uh
he's probably muted
so i think that the host can unload i
i just i just asked him don't you yeah
but you can unmute him
yourself uh can i i think i'm not the
host then
i cannot i can only ask to unmute him
i thought we were the hosts
how funny yeah i think mother has
dropped from the line
okay hey mozart is still there
send us a chat if you're if you're there
um
yeah rahul do you want to answer a
question
sure yeah but all this matters
sorry oh risk questions
about that yes okay so could you repeat
the question um
oh but my question is there seems to be
like a a variety of definitions of risk
measures for
multi-stage programming right so i'm
sure like you have seen something that
we all have seen various definitions
do you have a sense about like like what
should be the right definition
or is or how to how how to think about
risk matters in general
um i'm not an expert but so i can share
my very limited knowledge
on this topic i think uh so
as you probably know that uh
[Music]
uh you know as alex was referring to as
well right so it started with the
var you know value at risk measure and
then c bar
it's also called avar you know
conditional value at risk so those are
in practice those are kind of risk
measures that are you know quite
you know used very well but uh in the
last
15 or so years there's been an attempt
by in particular by alex shapiro and
then by also by other people to develop
a sort of
exymatic approach to to risk and
uh so
i mean it really depends on your
preference i mean there are you know you
different exams and then you end up with
different risk measures
when you go to a dynamic setting then i
think things become a lot more difficult
because the moment you consider risk or
you know which is not a risk neutral
measure
then the the uh the
the policies are going to be history
dependent right
and that really make you know it makes
things very challenging so people have
come up with their you know
notions of dynamic dynamic risk measures
and markov risk measures and all that
but
it all really depends on your
application and whether those
are relevant so that's all i can say
oh by the way i think chaba has more
questions for you in the in the chat box
but probably we don't have time to
answer them like
now like people need a break but yeah
okay can you type your answers in the
chat box so we can see them
oh i think i answered so i can see three
i answered all of them there are more
questions
well there is there is actually one more
there um
but uh yes i think i think we will have
to take a bit of a break so
we'll return in just 12 minutes so
so we just have a very brief break um
and
look forward to rebooting yeah
thank you okay okay thank you
thank you thanks to all the speakers